If you've actually done any kind of programming you wouldn't know that programming is
Frustrating it's confusing and sometimes it's even demoralizing
You remember when you just started you were so motivated. So passionate about the things you can do with it
All you see are people building their empires with it and affecting billions of lives with their lines of code
But no one ever told you about their failures the untold stories of people who have fallen and the hardships that brought to them
The reality is when we start programming and building things break things get stuck
Projects get scraped or even worse businesses die and jobs are lost startups fail and time is wasted
Failure after failure are happening every day
But all you see are the successes that coding brought to these different people but no one talks about the path to get there
Programming is hard and you will fail at one point
You will doubt yourself. You'll say you're not smart enough that you're not lucky enough or that you're not gifted enough
Worse other people will tell you that you're not meant for computer science. You're not meant to be an entrepreneur
You're not smart enough to be a programmer
You know what? I'll tell you that I think that some of you are not born to be programmers
You might be just wasting your time
You want to ignore my advice and close this video?
Good
Ignore my advice if that's you then it means you're bit stubborn
But you don't give up and you care
It means you fail all the time, but you pick yourself back up and you become stronger
It means you're dumb enough to try to do something impossible
but then
You make it loose you push technology to its limit and you're at the forefront of innovation and you push even further
And when people tell you that you can't do it
You go ahead and you do it when people tell you you're wasting your time
You go back and you work twice as hard and you come back and prove them wrong when people tell you you're crazy
It's a compliment to you
If that sounds like you then you are a true innovator and we need more people like you because we need more people
To face the impossible and conquer it
I don't care if you're just trying to pass a CS course or that you're building a rocket ship startup
What matter is that? You are not stopping until you reach your goal as a society
We have many many problems
But we tackle them heads on and we keep innovating to make our lives better on planet earth one of the problems
I care a lot about is natural disasters
I'm partnered with IBM today to talk about a global initiative
Called call for code which calls for developers to build something impactful and have a positive
Change across the world through their code as you know
There are hundreds of natural disasters every year like hurricanes earthquakes
floods volcanoes and wildfires
those affect numerous lives and causes tremendous damage to
Families across the globe if you strive for real impact, we desperately need you. This is why the
2019 call for code global challenge is a competition to ask people like you to build solutions
That help the health and well-being of these victims of natural disasters
There are so many aspects of that
We're talking about accessing medical records providing food and water safely controlling infectious diseases
building supply distribution networks and even getting access to mental health during natural disasters
We need all kinds of technologies here are a few examples of potential projects you like working on blockchains
Build secure supply networks to distribute aid to the people in need you like AI and NLP
Built BOTS to help real-time communication you're into data science
Analyze and predict what the affected populations need before they even ask for it
Every one of your project will matter and it will be for an extremely good cause now of course this is still a competition
so they have a grand prize of
$200,000 not only that the project with the greatest potential impact will be
Implemented through the IBM code and response initiative and receive open source support through the Linux Foundation
Last year's winning team project owl has already begun to deploy their solution in Puerto Rico as part of the code in response
So are you up for the challenge?
Do the impossible?
Be an innovator join the coffer code